well today we're gonna real movie about
the Kingsmen doesn't matter what's going
on reject nation Greg Aldi here John
Humphrey we got these cool hookup hats
they said you must recommend this movie
if we give you these hats and these
glasses that's not true at all actually
they said just don't release your honest
opinion on the movie until after the
18th we could do that we can do that and
fortunately you don't know when we're
shooting this our honest of pain is we
both really enjoyed the hell out of this
movie a lot yeah I had a great time keep
it simple for you guys alright because
I'm really grateful that while the
trailer does have a few spoiler things
that I wish could have been preserved a
little more for the movie like
especially dealing with like Colin Firth
character not even that is fully ruined
there's plenty to be had there that is
not in the trailer that is quite a
delight when you're watching the actual
film itself yeah much like we were
saying with it before it in a totally
different way it's like the trailer does
hint at some cool stuff but almost
everything cool about the trailer has
more stuff do it's just that I don't
think this film is better than the first
Kingsman III don't because the first
one's fresh and it has it even stronger
emotional context something I knew won't
walks out of Kingsman for the emotional
aspect to it but you do it well coming
of age yeah beyond that word a part to
right now and with a part two to a
Kingsman story
what's all I really care for this is
that I can be invested in it and that be
really exciting really entertaining I'm
laughing I'm being enthralled by the
action that's exactly what I got it's
just a really excellent entertaining
film that continues to do like you know
like American assassin just came out
last week
American assassin very serious five
thriller I'm like this is my love
Kingsman a really fun incredibly
detailed and
creative spy action comedy and and
that's all that's all I could have asked
for it's a really enjoyable film yeah
well it takes advantage of kind of all
the best things about now and all the
best things about an older school spider
moving comes out with a really cool
blend of the two and one of my favorite
things about the second one was that
they did ramp up both the humor and the
scope world it's more ridiculous the
flaws that I find with that don't
definitely outweigh the film at all
whenever I find a flaw with it my flawed
ends up going back to well here's why
Kingsman one I thought it was better
because Kingston one you know this
aspect better there's like emotional
aspects to it that I felt they could
have honed in on a little bit more ahead
of it if I hope if I go into here it
would it would be but there are things
that they do their characters they
decide to give you know a decent decent
jump wants to you know that are on one
hand you're like oh cool like they're
actually utilizing this character from
the first movie or they're utilizing
this news after in an interesting way
flip side to that though there are some
there's a character I can definitely
think of who does return where you're
like okay I guess we're not in the movie
anymore yeah except this person's just
not in the movie now you'll probably
know right when you know right when it
happens it's like it's weird there's
like a balancing scale like oh you
brought that kick oh just write them out
but come on yeah and there's some cool
new characters in here specifically the
standout new character without a doubt
is Pedro Pascal's of character whiskey
because in this movie as you see in this
trailer at Kingsman is basically
targeted by the Golden Circle which is
kind of like Spectre meets Goldfinger
one of those shadowy organizations with
a world domination scheme and a lot of
firepower
yeah and Julianne Moore is the head of
it and basically they target Kingsman
and basically most of Kingsman is
obliterated so they have to work with
their like their cousin the American
side of London Kingsman is this dates
man their doomsday plan basically ends
up being together yes and the Statesmen
side is is quite interesting it's not as
fascinating or as cool and
terms of the world exploration of the
Statesmen but it comes with a cool set
of characters that's the most life of
party
Pedro Pascal's character whisky yes his
performance is freakin awesome the way
he uses his revolvers is so badass I'm
like that's the kind of Western revolver
action on the one and it scene yeah
that's what I've been worn is it's like
out of a video game I love it I mean and
alert the lasso lasso to is really
badass yeah sure he probably accounts
for the newest freshest you know action
stuff in this movie yeah because there
are a lot of those like really awesome
one shot or it looks like one shot
anyway yeah yeah but you know in terms
of stuff that we didn't get the first
time his action scenes are the freshest
absolutely yeah nothing tops the church
scene from the first Kingsman it's gonna
be freakin hard to if you don't compare
you know exactly what Kingsman part one
was and you just accept this as a
standalone movie it's a pretty damn good
movie it's a it's a solid sequel for
sure they bother with things that you
wouldn't have to like they do expand the
world and there is more humor and there
is more action but you know they do
bring a couple you know surprisingly
nice emotional beat egg Z whereas I feel
like the first one takes more time to
have a little more emotional context
here they're like eggsy's mom is the
abusive stepdad those things that really
play a very specific character arc for
eggsy you still get some stuff here that
if I tell you it'll ruin the film
because there are some delightful things
in his personal life story that was like
yeah oh wow that's I didn't see that
coming yeah and so the nicest surprises
about that movie are on that side of the
fence attacks you wish that it had a
little more time to explore yeah maybe
just a bit further because it could have
given it some a bit more emotional
context but yeah for a sequel it does
amp up the fun a lot more yeah that's
the number one thing I probably could
have asked for this although there are
some things that are in the trailer that
you might want more of it you don't
really get there's at least like one
character like Channing Tatum's barely
in the movie yeah that's not in this
well there's there's a reason for that
yeah it is you know just pound for pound
it is a bit of a bummer that you don't
get to watch him kick ass the whole
movie and one thing about like Kingsman
one ends on this note of like this is a
perfect move
that could have sequels that's what I
love about it like you could see a
franchise and you actually do want a
franchise out of it this one has aspects
to it where you're like I like the
casting specifically you got three main
new actors with big names Halle Berry
Jeff Bridges and Channing Tatum and I'm
like I like the casting here they kind
of feel like they're being used more to
set up for sequels though as opposed for
just being strong players for this
specific one why get these huge actors
for this specific movie yeah and I feel
like they could their talents could be
used a Jeff Bridges too in the Jeff
Bridges thing yeah I guess if it ain't
broke don't fix it and then Halle Berry
gets probably more screen time than
chanting Tina but even the way her
channels like Suze likes being set up
for sequels he's cut it off in the
middle for me because I didn't think she
was useless and I liked what she brought
to it but yeah I thought like you know
we bothered to cast you yeah and they're
good a bit more any complaint I have
there's nothing in this movie that stood
out to me as like ah what were you
thinking or what a bad choice there's
just stuff that could have become more
or yeah utilize more effectively sure
there's maybe one plot point and I was
just like I don't get why you needed to
do that yeah I feel that halfway through
the second act it kind of drags a little
bit samey and it's I think it's because
of the fact that they're introducing the
Statesmen and the Statesmen like I said
is it the characters are more
fascinating than the world of the
Statesmen because when you got like
British classy spy you know that's
that's a certain kind of energy then you
go to Kentucky yeah very different type
of vibe and mood it kind of slows it
down just a little bit but then it
eventually picks it back up and ramps it
up the like especially the finales crazy
pack the finales bomb by the way family
is great no he's right and although
there's kind of drags a little bit a
half way through the second act the
finale is really fast-paced partway
throughout - I started to zone a little
bit and be like I'm feeling the ass
moving then a little bit in it in the
fenomena finish yeah yeah there are some
things that are a little bit like sequel
syndrome for sure there are some things
where I'm like right when I was done
with the movie I was able to be like
well this is a little too similar in
terms of plot yeah to the fur
this is a little too like yeah this few
places yeah yeah especially in the
finale especially with what's happening
in the big finale their plot elements to
it dealing with Julianne Moore's bill
and his character what's going on with
the world like I'm like this feels way
to Remini at the same time though I'm
like well this is kind of a spoof fun
version of bond and I'm like bond was a
little revenge modern world domination
scheme every time and spies got to get
their gadgets yeah stop it and hey I
mean I I thought that Julianne Moore was
terrific in this I mean I was an
interesting character for sure he is an
odd and interesting character and I
really I don't think it's the
performance you'd expect even though you
know we're like seer talk in the
trailers it's like this is not what I
was expecting
yeah like yeah again there were
surprises to this and some of them were
in pretty significant parts of yeah
movie and I loved her whole compound
like all the island stuff I thought was
really cool even with like Julianne
Moore's character you know how like in
Samuel Jackson has the mummy know but
stupid tell and then she has like the
number one muscle thing with like a
special agent and I'm like that's
exactly what Julianne Moore has - but
then again that's like a Bond trope at
the same time that's a nice surprise -
they show that character with the ham
that comes out yeah that's like a more
advanced Winter Soldier arm I didn't
show you that in the trailer you don't
realize who that is and then when you
realize who it is really Oh things like
a clever like oh cool and we're not
gonna give it away little twist like
that made me invest that much more
because it didn't seem like they wanted
to forget about the last movie like a
bond does in total one of the coolest
things to me about this is that they do
carry certain things over and keep them
going and pay them off in certain ways
yeah well there's a jam-packed finale
and the trailer does show so I don't
feel like I'm spoiling this cuz the
trailer has moments where you see that
Taron Egerton and Colin Firth's
character they're fighting side by side
in a couple scenes yeah and that's
that's a delight cuz I cuz it dawned on
me when I was watching it like oh yeah
the first one you don't ever see them
fight side yeah yeah yeah it's just the
master you know hands the man to the
protege and he takes so it's cool and
also but I like the creative idea of how
they bring back Colin
first they don't reveal that in the
trailers I like what they infuse I'm
like yeah it's real like spy stuff yeah
it's like there's a ton about both these
movies it's super convoluted yeah but
you know in terms of yet bringing a
character back from the dead I really
like the way they handled him I'm
surprised because they could have
cheaped it and they didn't yeah that's
one of the more kind of memorable and
impactful subplots of this movie
absolutely absolutely and so it's things
like that it's like every complaint I
have everything that falls short or
doesn't develop enough or goes on too
long there are a bunch of other things
this movies kind of like a shotgun blast
because it is sort of bloated in the way
that sequels are it's just some of the
stuff that is bloated with is pretty
terrific yeah some of the stuff that's
bloated with just could have been a
little better
I feel like this movie starts to lose
points for me my personal opinion starts
to lose points for me when I compare it
to the first one and I'm like the first
one did this a little bit better so then
this one loses points but in terms of
what this movie is just on it's just a
terrifically entertaining film if you
just want to have a damn good time at
the theaters ago people were laughing
the whole time and the opening scene
people were like open ten minutes of
this film are fantastic yeah well
there's at least one celebrity cameo in
there that is that is one of the wise
quite well yeah one of the nice the most
fun ones I've seen in quite some time
oh yeah I'm mark Strong in this movie -
he's fantastic more strong yeah like
Merlin was great in the first one I even
liked him more here you know yeah he's
fantastic
and this movie's a better than even
better what I think about like even if
it as a film isn't as solid and as fresh
I feel like - having seen the first one
twice - you know like it does kind of
clip in a nice pace and this one has its
rough spots they do bring in stuff that
I love just as much that I'm like yeah
how's this again like totally so if I
were to give it a rating I would give it
a four or five whiskey shots or like an
88% to two kids because you know that's
that's basically for a whiskey shot
there you go
yeah alcohol percentage movie was two
and a half two kilos I would give this
to - you lose on this rating system that
may
a lot of sense percentage-wise
absolutely if you did see Kingsman the
golden circle what you're probably
having yet because this review is coming
out early what are you looking forward
to most if you haven't seen it yet or if
you have seen it what do you which one
do you prefer
a little raw ladies gentlemen you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bow at your non-free
twitter instagram patreon.com slash the
real rejects become a patron eject to
die that's right do it